if you play shooters you know there is
nothing more about ass than a flick
getting his reload in just trying to be
debated
what are you doing
i thought it was a punch there's no you
can't be serious no please don't tell me
oh my god
how is that a frag how is this real life
flicks require flawless hand-eye
coordination absolute confidence in your
abilities and lightning fast reaction
speeds that's why when they do happen
they are some of the most satisfying
flashiest kills but before we get into
it i gotta remind you to flick on over
to the sub button and one tap the
notification bell and if you're done
let's count down the top 10 flicks in
esports
there is only one person who could start
off this list kenny s as he emerges out
of that smoke chris he's looking to
swing he's over the scope because
that is absurd he's got friction burns
on his wrist from that one kenya's will
go down in cs go history as one of the
greatest operas of all time he's a
flashy fragger whose famous flicks have
been etched into the history of
competitive counter-strike and while the
future of his career is still up in the
air his legacy is untouchable especially
since it includes plays like this insane
flick onto frozen at the berlin major
what kenny can do training his aim on
this
ct side chris j has tucked himself into
that corner with his new armored ak and
rops
i think he knows he's coming yep ammunic
he's full gray screen there it may look
a little silly but he can't see a thing
as he emerges out of that smoke chris
he's looking to swing he's over the
scope he can't
that is absurd he's got friction burns
on his wrist from that one
does get traded but kenny no one should
hit that only kenny s could pull off a
flick like that while getting shot from
two directions
mexican wow let's have a look at this in
slow mo yeah oh frozen
taking the ninth spot on our list is
everyone's favorite professor fallen and
his vertical flick onto zip nicks
oh
oh that is disgusting that is absolutely
disgusting he's so good with those
vertical flicks fallen is an absolute
god with the op his reaction time
accuracy and game sense cement him as
one of the greats but it's his ability
to pull off flicks on the y-axis that
separate him from the rest but g2 not
feeling pressured to peak they've got
the advantage
and he goes for it anyway that is a
filthy flick from the feet to the face
from fallen yes fallen has been pulling
off these portrait mode flicks for years
but it's this one he landed onto
astralis that still leaves us speechless
at iem winter 2021 astralis and team
liquid were going back and forth on
mirage in a 1v1 zip thought he was safe
to simply fall off stairs onto site it's
not like fallen would have a shot on him
right look astralis is putting some
frags together and the trades are
actually pretty snappy
oh i cannot believe they've actually
made a round of this
still doesn't go their way i'd love to
see the replay of that shot from fallen
oh
oh that is disgusting
coming in eighth is som and his crispy
ghost flick onto dynamic and somb still
gets this oh gross flick there onto
dynamic to finish it off beautiful som
is no stranger to crazy flicks if you
tuned into any of his cs go streams back
in the day you would catch them on the
regular and he's still hitting them even
after switching to valerian he made that
very clear when he closed out an ace
clutch at the valerian elite showdown
with a nasty flick i think come the
footsteps can he make the right guess
here might require quite the flick dodge
is the recon dot the tap comes in the
pressures there the flick misses from
som and there goes dynamic once again
he's going to throw his stick it but
there goes saul looking to push forward
that's going to take dynamic off of the
off of the defuse of the spike
and some trying to play this one
perfectly the perfect oh that's nice
for the ace as well
coming in in seventh place is mj in this
beautifully placed flick under steel as
soon as mj sounds the alarm it'll be
instantly reinforcing this position oh
what a dirty shot from mj dragadelphia
is a wonderful land event for fresh
blood rank-ass kids with global mutes
and pros banned for participating in
valve sponsored events all that is to
say we guarantee you've never heard of
mj before but you won't be able to
forget this shot just watch him flick
steel's head clean off but his uh his
defense elsewhere is actually in z with
a very quick rotate available he's got
two players in z one of them being up in
heaven right now so as soon as mj sounds
the alarm it'll be instantly reinforcing
this position oh what a dirty shot from
mj as he just pins steel to the wall
next shot's coming in everybody seems a
little bit threatened right now nobody
wants to be next up to be just skewered
into the fence line
grabbing the sixth spot on your list is
wardell and this beautiful clutch flake
onto gmd was the snake in the grass the
spoiler but look at that from wardell
that is so crazy by now everyone knows
that wardell is a bit of a madman and
for a long time his proficiency with the
operator was unrivaled in fact the
operator actually matches his
personality quite perfectly it's loud
flashy and incredibly strong and at na
challengers 2 waradel did what he does
best by deleting gmd from the server
with a nasty opt flick clutching the
round with only five hp
i think historically this corner is
checked but not this time around he's
gonna spray down two and it's a one v
one wardell on five hp seconds left as
game one looks to find his kill wardell
creeper oh he finds the flick he finds
the kill in tsm back in the win column
5 hp with no information on where his
opponent would be coming from and yet
wardell does what he does best and
that's half impact
you know you're cracked when shroud
can't even believe it
okay
all right just keep buying ops dude
forget what i said
holy [ __ ] how did he lose that
starting off the second half of this
list is cirque and this sound barrier
breaking flick out from this attack now
they can boost him up he's going hunting
what who did he even kill i don't
understand cirque is loki one of the
most dynamic operas in cs go right now
his aggression and consistency rival
simples at times and his flicks are so
insane that people have started calling
him the wrist breaker doesn't quite spot
him as the smoke dissipates so they
allow them towards the site he will see
a foot and he'll take the fight
over froze device with the first oh suck
the wrist breaker and if you want a
perfect example of how fast his flicks
can be just watch this play from esl one
new york or cirque killed lucky with a
flick so fast you wouldn't know who died
without looking at the kill feed
advantage extended for g2 they're going
to have the perfect pincer here they can
have one short one throwing a spanner in
from the doors in the form of laminec
and three on long not if cirque
completely rips the short presents out
from this attack now they could boost
him up he's going hunting what who did
he even kill i don't
understand okay short lovely 20th brag
let's see number 21.
okay sure can we slow that down a little
more yeah enhance enhance x-ray
taking the fourth spot on our list is
guardian and this vac worthy flag he
landed on duprey phase you have to
admire how much pressure they're keeping
on australis at the moment oh
my god
guardian is perhaps one of the most
beloved pros in cs go he's selfless
kind-hearted and will absolutely
decimate your team with the op how does
he work back in it's gone toward the
dumpster that means guardian knows
exactly where to load
he's got all
five but one of his finest moments might
be this insane flick from the london
major there's niko but he can't get back
out that molotov has got him weirdly
trapped he's gonna go down that was a
great idea and between phase you have to
admire how much pressure they're keeping
on australis at the moment oh my god
that is one of the most incredible shots
i've seen in a long time guardian yeah
that's right guardians said smoke is
nothing but grey air and blasted dupree
away never forget there is no safety
when guardian is on the server
the third place on our list goes to the
time pure showed us the only thing
better than one flick
is two
have they heard him seems to be the case
finds the first shot resets knows where
else it is 1v1
at vctna challengers 3 pure was in a 2v1
against 100 thieves things looked grim
but he was able to sneak all the way
onto site and two quick flicks later the
round was his yeah lockdown off the
board too as aaron was fragged out so no
alts in play here it's just all gonna
come down to fragging and it's an op and
a marshall versus two rifles and
everyone from 100 is now fully healthy
thanks to the heel eco catching bcj as
well adds insult to injury op shot
missed
not looking good here for except
a pure snuck on have they heard him
seems to be the case finds the first
shot resets knows where else it is 1v1
oh
the red bull clutch out of pure
an absolute electric quickscope form
with a little bit of fireworks he'll end
it in the same fashion what a crazy
flick here
that might be an aim lab flick as well
today
our runner-up play comes from klebs with
his hiko 2.0 flick
does manage to drop the first kill but
look at this clips one two and three
massive round from him and what the
every once in a while we get a highlight
that comes from an unknown place a
country is so elusive and upside down
it's almost fictional
australia i'm talking about australia
in map three of the semi-finals of
cybergamer intermediate season 12
australian cs go player caleb klebs long
hit one of the most remarkable flicks
since he goes legendary in human
reaction
sorry guys burskie does manage to drop
the first kill but look at these clips
one two and three massive round from him
and what the [ __ ]
it was so unbelievable that the caster
up and left so ludicrous that the whole
vod has been wiped from the internet
this lone twitch clip is all that
remains
and finally taking the number one spot
is simple the time he
well did the usual simple [ __ ] and
deleted someone off the face of the ears
nasty stuff but simple's gonna get
himself no
at this point simple has become one of
those if you know you know things he is
so good at so many different things it's
hard to pick out any one highlight that
stands out they're all that good but
this flick is really something else grim
had to be feeling some kind of way when
simple flicked to his head and
wallbanged him into oblivion
grimm's gonna clear that one back simple
almost falling as well here gotta be
cautious with that off swinging round
simple big reposition
i think we got to see that simple shot
again that first one yeah was at least
jumping i think so yeah yeah nasty stuff
but simple is going to get himself oh
that
is something special as i said there are
no words to describe what he does just
feelings
you need a whole protractor to be able
to figure out how many degrees this
flick was it comes
through the wall
that was some
jw off screen
one more time one more time
barely a scope flick shot like
what okay so that was the top 10 flicks
in esports if you feel like we missed a
flick let us know down in the comment
section below thanks again for watching
and i'll see you in the next one
who